if I got a plate of chicken strips with
that sauce on it I'd be like we've maxed
it out this is fun but no more
well one two three four
okay what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings
and today we're joined by Kumail
Nanjiani you probably know him best from
his Academy Award nominated films a big
sicker as well as Dinesh on HBO's
Silicon Valley now in its sixth and
final season he also stars alongside
Dave Batista and Stuber which is set to
theaters on July 12th
Kamel Nanjiani welcome to the show hi
thank you for having me I guess so I
know that you're no stranger around
spicy food is it still a dream of yours
to have a show called sweating and
restaurants with your mouth yeah that's
my family's idea because I love spicy
food but even if it's a little spicier
start sweating so my threshold is is not
crazy high but even if I don't hit it I
start sweating but I don't think it's
gonna be fun for people to watch because
it really is very unsettling you're
gonna find out
[Music]
okay and I have said that I wanted a
fork and knife because I've messed up
with a hot stuff before I don't want it
in my eyes so I'm not gonna touch it he
knows what he's doing now all right so
this this will be for ya it's no big
deal
all right that's that's delicious
I like to look in your eye you have the
look of someone who's like you have no
idea what's coming to you
yeah people have seen it before yeah
you've seen it before you have a
conference about you in this that I find
very unsettling so during your
appearance on DAC Sheppard's armchair
expert podcast you said that you have a
goal of putting on 20 pounds of muscle
did you pick up any bodybuilding hacks
from your stupid co-star dave bautista
oh yeah he knows everything you know you
got to eat six meals a day he eats a lot
that's what I learned working with him
is that he's constantly eating you can't
hang do you find that meathead
stereotypes are sometimes unfair cuz I
had a phase where I was in the weight
room all the time and I actually found
myself really liking meatheads because
they're always down to spot you you know
they're always like very into what
you're doing you know I will say but
it's very refreshing to see huge dudes
really talking about men's bodies you
know they're like pointing at specific
things and they're like kind of touching
you and it's very I feel very safe
around them yeah there's a certain
community quality to it all right
I feel cared for and they're very very
supportive so you know this guy one
specific guy who's much bigger than me
is always like brother
I really respect people who work out
hard in the gym and I really respect you
so I was like that's the best thing I've
ever heard it's cool
[Music]
sauce Bay okay so it's a big transition
for a kids safe from New York to go to a
small liberal arts college in the
Midwest but I imagine the culture shock
must have been very intense showing up
in rural Iowa to go to Grinnell fresh
off the plane from Karachi in Pakistan
what was the best thing about living in
Iowa and then what was the worst thing
about living in Iowa oh wow
good question see I'm already starting
to sweat and I'm not even and you're
close to the eyes yeah but I'm not
touching it so I'm fine the best thing
about living in Iowa was I'd come from
like a very very intense like I came
from Karachi which is like you know like
New York is 20 million people you know
there weren't many Pakistani Union
people where I was I still felt like I
just felt a little bit special so the
best part of it was that it wasn't
really populated the worst part was that
it wasn't really populated by your three
you're like alright I need I need to go
somewhere else loved Iowa it was great
but at the end of the four years very
very very ready to move to a big city
and then of course you went to Chicago
and you were doing stand-up at the Cubby
Bear I used to live a car really you did
I used to live a couple blocks away from
there I live right by there - what were
the crowds like there cuz that
intersection could be kind of rowdy
rough as [ __ ] yeah and prouds were
really really tough at Cubby Bear I wow
that's crazy
cubby bear yeah that's where I met a
bunch of comedians for the first time I
think I might have met Pete Homestar for
the first time yeah they had an open mic
every week and there were these people
there who were not there for the comedy
and then we were like alright we're
gonna great news you're at a sports bar
you're all Cubs fans we're gonna turn
off the game and Kumail is gonna now
tell you how he feels awkward buying
condoms at the store and they were it's
a very tough crowd and they were okay
just being very vocal
[Music]
I actually want this so when the sixth
and final season of HBO's Silicon Valley
obviously a lot to unpackage but we
don't start with can you give us the
origins story behind rude boys on the
lot I don't see no season one or two
we're all just like nerds you know but
we really were like cultivating this
persona that we were like the bad boys
we will shoot at Sony which is this huge
like a bunch of stuff shoots there but
we consider that we were like we're the
bad boys everybody scared of us that was
like the joke we did so then we got
these jackets made for ourselves that
said rude boys on the lot and this
company had gifted us these scooters now
the scooters are everywhere there you
can like you know yeah with your iPad so
we would wear our jackets that said rude
boys on the lot these really Guardi
jackets I think they had huge dice on
them or something and we would ride
around in scooters and then the security
guard would that you can't do there was
a very sorry and then one of the great
scenes not only in the history of the
show but maybe all of cable TV is when
you guys are debating the most efficient
way to jerk off a auditorium full of 800
guys can you break down the mechanics of
that scene and how the math was written
for the jerk-off algorithm
apparently the math is all real and they
got Stanford like us too they got people
from Stanford to like do the math so
when you're looking at the board and all
the math is there that's all real
because we basically they were like what
are the factors if you did have to jerk
off every guy in this room quickly
what's the most efficient way and it
would have to be you know so it's two
dicks here two dicks here and you're
sort of jerking off four dicks at a time
right
but then there's more stuff cuz then
you're like well what's the math problem
with it
well height people's Heights are
different so you can't have two dicks
that don't align but it's not that it's
actually the dick to floor like it's not
the height and then this how long
someone's gonna last right and you have
to do the hot-swap on the way down you
don't want slowdowns like if a guy comes
once I go up here there's gonna be
another guy with similar girth and dick
to floor ratio so there's a lot of
things to consider yeah that was my
favorite scene to do other than that the
math is sound and then the math is
totally sound
then finally I'm sure through doing the
show you've been in contact with a fair
number of startups and venture
capitalists do you find that there any
more or less outrageous than the version
that you portray on the show they're
worse I mean they had to keep like
upping it they actually took something
from the show from real life that they
had Gavin Belson who's the bagger on the
show and they had him say it pretty much
word-for-word and it was so unlike Abel
that they had to rewrite it because it
made the villain on the show too
villainous just repeat word-for-word
what this real guy and realize that it's
funny because they watch our show and
they're like it's hilarious everyone
else here is like that and we're like
you're like that do so it's great
they're so arrogant that they think
we're not talking about them
specifically everybody else it's perfect
I taste the pineapple okay yeah that's
the first one that you start feeling I'm
leavin missing want to start sweating
even though I'm not in crisis yet I will
be in crisis but I will look like I'm a
crisis way before I am actually in
crisis well I can't wait I can't wait
come out I can't so
rappers and professional athletes are
always posturing about who's the best
gamer does that sort of rivalry exist in
the comedy circuit no not many comics I
know we're actually into gaming I'm one
of the few people I know who's like
really really into it and I am very good
at it and you know what you can't out
those credentials because a lot of
people talk but no one was back in 2011
breaking down the best video games of
all time on g4 so you can talk - that's
right yeah I was cheap for talking video
games before like you know video games
became like super cool I mean they were
cool then - but then I had a podcast
called the indoor kids with my wife
Emily Gordon and we would talk about
video games every week so my my video
game credentials are pretty legit and
then you've said that it's the only
medium that's improved over the last
thirty years can you unpackage that I
mean you know like movies there are some
movies from like the 40s 50s 60s that
are always gonna be among the best
movies of all time but video games
because of Technology are better than
they have ever been I could the actual
products are getting better and better
and more complicated and more narrative
ly complex and satisfying and the game
systems are getting better in the AI is
getting better so I really think it's
the only medium we have that in terms of
quality is getting better literally
every year as an Academy Award nominated
screenwriter is there a game that you
just have to tip your cap to from a
writing perspective when your buddy Pete
Holmes was on the show he had a lot of
nice things to say about the character
development and Red Dead Redemption I
think the grand theft auto games are
great because they had this really like
the mark the hit is so narrow they're
you know they're like sort of satirical
I'm heightened and really funny but you
still care about the characters that's a
very hard thing to do to have like a
satirical world where you really really
care about the story Skyrim I thought
was really interesting because the
narrative is cool but you sort of
create your own narrative as well that's
the thing with fantasy worlds you know
it's got to feel lived in it's gonna
feel like there's a history it can't
feel like it started when the game
started and those games do a great job
of that
like why you did the history of the
world that you're in is so fully fleshed
out okay is this when things get real I
think for a spaceman like yourself a
spaceman thank you
do you have another one or two sauces
before it gets a little hairy over
unbearable yeah okay yeah all right
Kumail we have a recurring segment on
our show called explain that grammar we
do a deep dive on our guests Instagram
interesting pictures that need more
context so I'll bust off the laptop I'll
show you the picture you just tell me
the bigger story does that sound good
uh-huh do you get scared each time you
do you like ugh I gotta do that again
do you like dread it each time because
you know exactly what's coming you know
what I think happens is that the
pressure of the interview right this is
the first time that you and I have ever
met and I have to help create this
energy and create this connection with
you you know and I think that that takes
my mind off the sauces so like these
could all be this sauce and I probably
won't even notice oh that one's bad huh
it gets a little weird over here all
right what's the craziest thing that you
saw at WrestleMania oh my god um so we
were front-row for the match between
Dave Batista and Triple H cuz you know
friends with Batista truly loved them I
remember being there in the commentary
tables were in front of us so it was us
commentators and then the tables and I
remember being like wow these tables are
shoddily made the construction seems
awful and then Dave lawn landed on one
and like splattered and I said oh okay
that's well makes sense you don't want
like oak furniture what was a more
memorable nerd rite of passage for you
oh I know Martin or meeting Stanley Wow
okay okay you know love them both love
Game of Thrones
I mean Stanley has done so many things
and I remember I interviewed him we kind
of I kind of started making fun of
Superman and he loved it he thought it
was like really fun and he started
making fun of Superman with me and I was
like that's awesome I got to make fun of
Superman with Stanley and now you know
obviously he's gone so meeting Stanley
was definitely extremely extremely
exciting and he was just very warm and I
mean look at him he's got his arm around
my shoulder he's not doing the hover
hand or anything one more for you yeah
speaking of meeting your heroes they say
you should never meet your heroes yeah
they do say that but I've been very
fortunate and that the heroes I've met
have all been wonderful and that's
obviously David Duchovny and Gillian
Anderson Mulder and Scully yeah it's my
favorite show of all time I used to do a
podcast about it there was a little time
in my life where if I like something I
would do a podcast about and then I
realized that's terrible don't make
stuff you love into work anyway my
favorite writer on the show Darrin
Morgan he was like do you want to do
this show I said yes of course I was
really really terrified and that's the
last day of shooting I was like once I'm
done I'll ask him for a picture and the
reason I'm smiling laughing like that is
cause David Duchovny was blowing in my
ear just before it all right well the
x-files talk it is a lovely segue to the
next wing
what is this Hellfire
[Music]
oh you know what when you eat a spicy
thing
there's the spice and then there's
another flavor impossible to describe
sort of metallic something shows up and
that's the first time I feel that and
I've never been able to articulate
there's something there's like another
ghost floating around in there and he
has just shown up I'll do one more bite
there you go dad flavor [ __ ] that flavor
I do like it though I like how it Dave
right same there's something about the
spicy thing that shows up mm-hmm that's
like flitting around it's like hey I'm
gonna be here for a while make myself at
home yeah okay so by all accounts you're
one of the biggest
x-file obsessives on the internet as we
talked about you had that podcast where
you deep dive individual episodes and of
course recently got to guest star in the
series revival what's your take on the
infamous home episode Oh a lot of
Mythology around I love that episode
that's one of my favorite episodes
people remember it obviously has a very
intense episode because it's got some
graphic violence in it but it's also one
of the best written ones as the world
becomes more modern it homogenizes so
all these like weird towns are
disappearing because at the Internet or
because the corporations are moving
there instead of weird restaurant now
it's Applebee's and this episode really
is about one of those weird little towns
pushing back against encroaching modern
civilization so I think it's uh I want
to talk about this episode for a long
time so I can put off what's coming next
and then I know what you are doing the
podcast one of the ways that you'd
prepare for it is by combing old message
boards so you could see what fans were
saying about the episodes when they
actually aired yeah in doing that did
you see a difference an Internet
discourse in the mid nineties versus
today so the x-files will have started
in 93 it was really the first show that
had a following on the Internet right
people were very respectful to each
other then the conversations were very
smart
and I would see it only took a couple
years as internet was spreading I saw
the first like afk away from keyboard
show up I saw the first like emoji show
up which was like you know the smiley
face which is the the colon with the
parentheses first show up and I saw it
turned from being like a lovely place of
discourse to you're a [ __ ] idiot when
it happened so quickly but I saw that
happen through people talking about
x-files episodes it was awesome
so for me this is probably the ceiling
of what I would eat and consider
enjoyable like I would eat I would if I
got a plate of chicken strips with that
sauce on it I'd be like we've maxed it
out this is fun but no more well one two
three four
[Music]
at this point I want to know I'm eating
a big enough bite that people at home
aren't thinking that I'm not doing the
thing is that is that enough for more
that's plenty
that's plenty
so you've worked alongside directors
with some of the biggest cult followings
in Hollywood from Jordan Peele to Judd
Apatow to Mike judge and then I know
that they're all unique in their own
ways but do you see a character trait
that runs through all of them yeah
yes I do see you're not the only one
who's been giving it hard here I can
make difficult yes there is a character
trait in common next question I think
that they're all other than being
obviously very smart and good at what
they do am i sweating a lot a little bit
but you know what come on said some
crazy things
what if you decide laughs people
spitting in buckets
screaming pacing around bailing to take
a break for a little bit I've seen it
all that okay there's no rules here you
know okay yeah I could tell what is the
[ __ ] Wild West over here
[Music]
ready
[Music]
there's a picture of a nuclear bomb on
[Music]
this one has an extra special something
I will say that the first time the ghost
showed up was here
and then this one you know what like for
instance in terms of spices I'll bring
it back to videogames
I remember when he went from like NES to
Super Nintendo that was a big leap then
PlayStation 2 the PlayStation 3 wasn't
so big or place to be the president for
wasn't so big this feels like a Super
Nintendo to a PlayStation show like
we're in the [ __ ] big leagues now
[ __ ] for real this is real so I
understand that your nickname at one
point was Kemal biryani
can you explain biryani to the people
who are watching right now and I in your
opinion is it one of the great dishes of
all time there's a show on Netflix
called chef's table and there's an
episode I'm gonna get [ __ ] get
through this there's an episode about us
my fan who has a restaurant in London
and there's like a forty second thing
where she's making the beer honey and
she opens it and she pulls it out and I
cried I it looks so good that I cried
because I know that feeling of being in
my grandmother's house but you know the
reality is there but you don't smell it
cuz it's been sealed when she opens it
and you smell it and you all the colors
the rice in the meat come out and I just
start crying
[Music]
is their Pakistani dish that's hard to
find in the u.s. that you think could
really flourish as a mainstream menu
item I would say that kebab role Katia
role could be on every corner and I
think it's like a good entry point for
most people I have to blow my nose do
people do this
mm-hmm everyone close your eyes pause
the cameras hold God
[Music]
I think it's really gross hold down
ivory look at my phone and see what my
face looks I ever turn my phone on we
could talk movie star [ __ ] yeah I've now
felt less like a movie star in my life
and I've never felt like a movie star
but I've now felt less like one I admire
your [ __ ] Drive man you know what
sucks about these people some state in
the beginning they're like I'm not so
bad I'm fine
looks like a houseguest and then like a
few minutes later they're like [ __ ]
on your couch like they don't they don't
announce themselves as being horrible
it's just right when you're like I'm
gonna go find like right now to kind of
see this coming around the bend I knew
it they were all gonna be horrible but
like this one and the one before the
immediate sensation isn't oh wow that
was really intense it really builds
which is a bigger accomplishment for you
being named one of times hundred most
influential are getting name checked in
a jeopardy clue times most influential
one was funny cuz people were upset that
Putin wasn't on it and they were like
kumail's on it but Putin's not on it and
I'm like I guess the Jeopardy one is
better because my parents were very
impressed they were very excited about
Jeopardy the what jeopardy Wow speaking
of your parents being proud was your dad
who I understand is a jeans aficionado
proud to see you on gqueues best-dressed
man of the am I supposed to ignore
what's going on
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last way
you don't have to are you doing it to
him I'm not gonna do it on mine
like I got you come out there you go
what's going on hold on let me see it
make sure my face is okay before we good
this last hold on gotta check it I look
like I'm currently being waterboarded I
think you look great I think you look
great
Wow let's go picture you good good pose
wow I really okay here we go
here we go classic gap classic damn
cutting off a corner
[Music]
so alright here we are at the final
stage of hot ones the final boss we've
talked a lot about your nerd cred which
spans from the x-files all the way to
get Amin and everything in between but
one thing that we haven't hit on is your
love for old-school cartoons so here I'm
gonna hit you with a wing 10 pop quiz
about one of your more niche off-piste
obsessions and that is he-man so if you
can drill three he-man pub trivia
questions under these circumstances I
think the Internet will be very
impressed okay first question
true or false the he-man action figures
actually predate the comic books and
cartoon series um
yes correct that is true yeah they made
them and then they made the cartoon as I
got advertising who voiced he-man in the
1987 film Masters of the Universe was it
how you long Bruce Willis or Dolph
Lundgren Dolph Lundgren it is Dolph
Lundgren yeah ding ding ding ding ding
what color is evil Linds hair it's black
or is it dark blue or is it white the
cap is black her hair is white her hair
is white her hair is white but you know
what come on seriously
look it up go ahead hold on two out of
three on the he-man pop quiz nothing to
sneeze at that hair white hair that
little white I don't know only not black
it's certainly not nobody's ever seen
that how do you find them now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet even man threat cause this camera
this camera in this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
you there's one little picture I can
find why she has white hair and I don't
know if that's canon all right stupor
comes out in theaters July 12th me dave
bautista Betty Gilpin Natalie Morales
your Sorvino ego ace who's an amazing
action star go see this movie
[Applause]
[Music]
just flashback to my dad great
grandmother's funeral so thank you for
that hey what's going on hot ones fans
this is Sean Evans checking in to say
thank you so much for watching today's
episode but I have a stern warning for
those of you out there who've been
watching us now for nine seasons and
have still not subscribed this is your
final warning subscribe or else
[Music]
[Music]